I think some of the most Machiavellian
characters in Game of Thrones are those
who aren't born to the great families a
character like Petyr Baelish
Littlefinger who is the treasurer or
master of coin as we call it of the
realm when the books open
he's although he's born to a noble house
it's a very weak noble house his lands
are a few acres and a kind of run-down
tower house and he has a lot of sheep
and sheep pellets that's his an
irritants but he has his mind and he has
subtlety and he he climbs and he
maneuvers and he he has great skill with
finances which is something that a lot
of the higher born Nobles consider
beneath them worrying about money and
stuff like that so he's able to
accumulate more and more money and more
and more power and befriending everyone
he's everybody's friend he's always very
helpful and people find them very useful
to their schemes and as a result he gets
everybody's ear he gets involved in all
these plots he's probably the most
Machiavellian character in the game of
Thrones but book Littlefinger and
television show Littlefinger are very
different characters they're probably
the character that's that's most
different from the from the book to the
television show there was there was a
line in a recent episode of the the show
where he's not even present but two
people were talking about him and and
someone said well no one trusts
Littlefinger and Littlefinger has no
friends and that's true television show
Littlefinger but it's certainly not true
a book Littlefinger if book Littlefinger
in the book everybody trusts him
everybody trusts him because he seems
powerless and he's very friendly and
he's very helpful he helps Ned Stark
when he comes to town he helps Tyrion
you know he helps the Lannisters he's
always ready to help to raise money you
know he helps Robert Robert depends on
him to finance all of his his banquets
and tournaments and his other Follies
because Littlefinger could always raise
money
so he's everybody's friend but of course
there's the Machiavellian thing he's you
know everybody trusts him everybody
depends him he's not a threat he's just
this helpful funny guy who you can you
know call upon to do whatever you want
and to raise money and he ingratiate
himself with people when rises higher
and higher as a result it's tough to be
a ruler whether in Machiavelli's time or
today or in the Middle Ages or any time
in-between I wanted to reflect some of
this this realistic thing at the show
people facing very difficult choices
where it's not enough just to say I will
be good and wise and do the right thing
what is the right thing that's the
question
but in fact the right thing often in the
case of your characters and Game of
Thrones is vicious and appalling and an
address come in terms of removing your
enemies sometimes yes it is yes it is
because otherwise they may come back for
revenge
but not always I mean there's a there's
a level of complexity in Game of Thrones
- I mean I think you can argue I think
very convincingly that Joffrey the
teenage boy king in an effort to show
how strong he was and how you defied him
at your peril execute Eddard Stark at
the end of the first book and this is a
colossal mistake you know the the deal
that was set up where Ned was going to
plead guilty take the black go to the
wall would have removed him from the
board as a political threat and yet not
cause the entire North to rise in revolt
and would have been a much better
solution but Joffrey being like 14 years
old and a book made a very childish
decision so the harshest decision is not
always the wisest but sometimes it is